action bring me stronger Warriors  [Applause]  everybody step he stepped up brought  their best work and brought the passion  the woman came a story about women  pushing through to another side as  themselves  it's been so wonderful working with  these young women because they want to  give it their all there was no other  place we could shoot this film than  Africa it was just a no-brainer to tell  this story of our ancestors on the  continent with this amazing cast of  black women I do not want a husband I  want to be a soldier  all the actors as you see beautifully in  this scene are doing their own fighting  we did really have to feel like an army  it felt like we're all in the trenches  together I felt badass I felt strong  up